there's not a game there's not a game I
played in that I was huh a lot of people
remember the day when you got traded
from the Vikings to the Seahawks when
you got to Seattle
like once you finally got there and got
with the team what was that experience
like oh man if I could if I could uh put
it to you
just as lame as I could those was
probably the worst years of my life just
because it came with so much my anxiety
is that it's worse when I go into
unfamiliar situations when did you
realize that you had an anxiety disorder
when I was diagnosed I still didn't
acknowledge it but when I started
noticing is when I started speaking or
going into different environments so
particularly the press conference with
the Seahawks my shirt was sweating it
had to bring me water a couple of times
doing my press conference what do you
recall as the worst instance of you
acting out as a result of anxiety my
worst one I would say you know the Super
Bowl snn was it going to take me through
it who were y'all playing what was going
on throughout Super Bowl week and what
was the end result of it thinking about
it now man I can't even really I did it
so we're down to the Super Bowl of
course the year in New York we were
playing on Denver Broncos or Peyton
Manning we had the practice facility we
had to practice inside because it was
cold snoring and going into the
interview I had just set out the
previous game with a concussion so the
question is how do you feel you know
getting Percy Harvin back and you know
getting some of y'all power back you
know getting ready to play this you know
tough Denver Broncos team and the
response was we made it here without him
so you know whether he player don't play
you know
we gonna be good so how did you respond
to that fast water we in the meeting
room and I kind of asked him about like
y'all bow like you know what's going on
that you're happy to put me like this
happens on all season
I was so already wrapped up it didn't
even probably matter always answer was
anything he could have said I still was
going with you you know I was I was
already at ten so I'm adding ten point
five or whatever so I was already there
I had some sources in the Seahawks
locker room that witness that and they
said you punched him into a laundry
hamper did that actually happen let's
just say we got we we we we we we locked
up you know the owners had to come in in
the locker room and the fact of the
hitting them into the trash can and uh
all that type stuff it was true I said
right was this little feels bad that the
whole situation egg with you will we
keep harping on it that's what made it
back cuz it was team pitches that day
and we secrecy tents in the picture you
don't see like a team ready that you
place whoa
you gave him a blackout five minutes
before the team phone what happened next
beast mode was a peacemaker and uh he
was kind of just like don't people want
you to do this and that like that should
do this my said we can move on and you
know let's just move on so and actually
that came the day of the game we kind of
gave doubt but they do why we warming up
keep returning us out and all that we
kind of just lame and it's a Super Bowl
and that's it's all good casting I've
never really had dentists before but to
finally tell you know my man dougie and
golden that some situations they were on
your boy one hundred percent
[Music]
what was your solution to kind of help
cope with these anxiety situations that
popped up now you're looking at a guy
that I was at the Mayo Clinic
and did I had at least seven
prescriptions that I was to take from
zoloft and all the other ones I was
taking and the only thing they do really
seem to work is when I was smoking
marijuana how often did you smoke person
there's not a game there's not a game I
play then that I wasn't huh and that's
what I want the world to kind of see
today is it's not a stigma and you know
people doing it and getting in a whole
bunch of trouble it's people that's just
living a regular life that just got
fishes seized or just may want to enjoy
themselves it's a natural way to do so
how crazy is that that y'all still win
the Super Bowl despite all this chaos
and we rock thanks for kicking it with
us subscribe to be our to check out more
dope videos like this one